here's your sound sync oh this is the
sound sync
[Music]
right there right there doesn't even
blow bubbles with Play-Doh do you know
how jarring this must be for people
listening to this podcast right now yeah
it is I'm sorry just look at yourself I
think we just roll right into it like
this yeah
trust us we can just roll right into it
like this
you're hitting the ground running right
wow
welcome to halfway through this is our
intermission here
[Music]
this is a good place to start oh yeah it
is
welcome back to the chord or digital
podcast everybody episode
173. we're glad that you're here with us
thanks for being here with us we've got
on the show today for you we've got
shrimp Nick himself Legend legend of all
shrimpness we've got Jordan Allen that's
the whole intro for me yep yeah
and and Matt Karen's of course don't eat
it I don't know what is going on but uh
I had a few things to do before this and
the boys have been sitting in the
podcast room for the last 10 minutes and
things are getting weird
so uh yeah you can say that we're eating
Plato it's only weird
Play-Doh yeah yeah
you used to eat a lot we've all tried it
yeah wait a minute no so okay so Jake
yeah we were talking earlier about who
ate Plato it was just me no no that
that's like the guy who's like everyone
pees in the shower yeah he's like no you
do yeah you do Play-Doh is like flavored
it's salty it's salted for your
convenience
okay so I'm talking about I don't eat it
now but I remember as a child I tried
eating Play-Doh everything did you guys
not try using Play-Doh I think an
important line to draw here you said you
tried eating it does that mean that you
tried once and learned your lesson yeah
okay because that's the difference
man maybe you can explain your
experience so wait are we gonna are we
gonna use the first I don't know because
this is different than peeing in the
shower though Nick there's some
legitimate function to peeing in the
shower okay yeah uh hunger you could eat
Play-Doh for Hunger Hunger a child who's
starving honestly and probably better
than nothing
you don't know do you think it's any
worse for you
let's let's find out what's in Play-Doh
real quick yeah look it up it says on
the back it says non-toxic we know
they're totally fine and it contains
wheat yeah yeah that's the biggest
warning on the back is that it contains
wheat if you're allergic to wheat
products mixture of water salt and flour
that was a wheat head actually it's an
award-winning combination it would be
better than nothing so it actually isn't
bad for you this this is Beats most
breakfast cereals it's pretty cool
French Pizza
I'm sure someone's done it but you could
like bake Play-Doh right you could make
a look we could give it a shot a little
cake I would give it a shot honestly now
that I know that it's good for you Jake
said
I think if we make it more food shaped
then it would be uh easier to digest I'm
sure yeah I'm really shocked by this
okay so Hasbro Hasbro says that it's a
primarily a mixture of water salt and
flour make sense well it's 2004 United
States patent indicates it's composed of
water a starch-based binder
retrogradation inhibitor salt lubricant
certificate surfactant preservative
hardener humectant fragrance and color
so some of those other things might get
to you eventually but if you were
starving yeah you know what it might be
okay first or worse for a dose of food
the smell of Play-Doh you're telling me
that's an intentional fragrance they add
in they're like oh we just want that
chalky
Secret
sales Matt made a little hot dog I made
a hot dog out of it so well if you guys
ever have kids just wait because Plato
will be come a thing again in your life
very quickly yeah I believe it I mean I
guess you kind of have if you're a
Hasbro you kind of have to make it so
you can eat it and not die it's like
crayons right there would be too many
lawsuits kind of like oh crayons too
were you cram man I wasn't much of a
crayon eater did you eat crayons
are you in the U.S Marines oh uh that's
all the Marines do that yeah because
that's that's the joke yeah they're
crayon eaters
uh I just felt like it warranted some
reaction
I don't know man we're just in a goofy
mood today yeah I think that's probably
because you guys have been working on
something pretty goofy we've been
working it's very true very very weird
and Goofy yeah the last two weeks yeah
that's a really professional impressive
yeah
enjoy your Play-Doh while we tell you
all about it
and I've been working on putting Steven
Seagal in John Wick for yeah to sort of
uh test the strength of the franchise of
John Wick you know because uh Steven
Seagal is a horrible human being in a
lot of ways that we'll describe later uh
and in the crew video in much more
detail when that comes out
um but uh yeah it's just he's he's such
a terrible person that putting him in
the lead role of this uh insanely uh
Revenue generating and popular franchise
uh what would it how would it work
without Keanu Reeves yeah you know
somebody everyone loves let me just get
this out there off the bat you're
talking about Steven Seagal not as a bad
actor but as a bad human yeah like
morally uh look at every Leap every
League yeah
um do we want to go into that now or do
we want to save that for a little bit
and talk about how we did it first I
mean we feel like that's I want to
explore that I didn't we kind of know
that I didn't know this and I'd like to
vet some of the yes please no I think I
actually think that would be a really
good exercise is if you vet okay some of
these stories uh but yeah I mean as far
as like approach you know it kind of
came about because Matt and I were
having a debate on the John Wick series
and it's like I'm personally of the
mindset that you know like James Bond
for example you replaced the James Bond
actor and it just keeps going and it's
like is John Connery or is it one of
those things where if you replace you
know Keanu Reeves it falls apart yeah
and I'm a big piano fan I'm like can you
have a job without Kiana yes exactly so
the real test is not only can you have
it without Keanu if you put Steven
Seagal in like one of the worst options
on the table could it survive that and
so we challenged the crew to all watch
this trailer that we produced and say
hey would you spend 18 watching this in
the theaters and that is how we we came
to the conclusion so check out the video
If you haven't seen yet it's out on the
channel already yeah it's live it's a
fun one uh unfortunately making it
required uh well me yes specifically me
to watch a lot of seagull content
um and Steven Seagal is uh it makes
really really bad movies especially now
I mean he had like a his Heyday you know
back in like the late 80s he was making
like actual good movies uh like
something like under siege and uh films
like that that were like action movies
yeah action movies yeah decent decent
action movies that people generally
liked and you know made a lot of money
in the Box yeah I think it's important
to denote this here when you say bad
movie I mean those two terms it's almost
disrespectful to the word bad movie
I see it all film a bad movie that's how
bad they are yeah I mean I'm talking
you literally you showed me a clip
from from one of them dude I don't even
know which one I legitimately thought
that I was watching and this is no
disrespect to all the starter filmmakers
out there but I legitimately thought
that it was like a 12 or 13 year old had
picked up a video recorder walked into
an Alleyway with their buds and filmed a
scene where a guy gets shot in the head
but then the guy gets shot in the head
and he falls down to reveal Steven
Seagal yes yes
everybody starts out that way but this
man has been making films for 40 years
dude yeah I mean it essentially is that
it essentially is like a 12 year old you
know filmmaker whatever who never really
grew up and is just writing his own
movies where it's like this hero complex
yeah it's a hero College how do I self
glorify myself it's crazy more than
anyone would the the language that he
writes for his own characters is
mind-blowing it's stuff that I wouldn't
have said in college you know in a
million years and it's like here he is
almost putting himself back in like that
age bracket desperately wanting to
reclaim that and being the most lewd
version of that version of himself it's
yeah it's really hard to watch some of
the stuff like a lot of the stuff got
cut from the trailer because it was too
lewd you said something important there
actually a key to all of these new new
films now because what what I was saying
earlier was that his 80s films and you
know early 90s they were decent enough
well it's because like he wasn't
necessarily the uh the executive
producer the producer the one that calls
all the shots in the film
um but he's made like 57 movies in his
entire career which is honestly it's
impressive it's a lot it's a lot of
movies to make
um you know but over time these movies
have gotten worse and worse as he's
gotten like larger and uh worse as a
human being
um and so like it's it's come to this
point where uh it and I think there's
one story that was mentioned about how
he he comes out of his trailer one one
time on set of something and he said he
just says like I read the best group
I've ever read in my entire life yeah
and then someone was like dude yeah who
who wrote it he's like me
so he writes his own movies yeah now you
know he's writing his own stuff and he's
no one's screening them at this point
he's just like I'm just making this yeah
uh and he's clearly not a great writer
so yeah man uh that's who's Distributing
these it's not what I wanted yeah that's
a good question I mean my guess is that
I mean look like a couple of them the
foreign markets are perfect if you're
Steven Seagal because you know you're a
western old action star uh you can make
movies for cheaper and people still will
want to see them because like you know
over here in the west we have such a
like just over saturation of really high
quality content it's not like that
everywhere else in the world you can
still sell a Steven Seagal movie like
that's the reality of it so he makes he
does fine yeah and I mean it's all
foreign audiences though like you're not
getting Americans going and watching
these unless it's for the meme I would
guess yeah I mean that's my little
outside take but again like feel free to
watch it before you you listen to the
rest of this but I mean that's kind of
the consensus that we came to after
showing the trailer to everybody it's
like people people are essentially drawn
to the meme like the meme level is so
high with this crossover that it's like
it's weirdly becomes attractive again
and it's the age-old scale of good bad
and Cinema where the best way I've heard
it described is it's not like hey this
is a poorly made film and therefore it's
bad it's bad because it's poorly made
and not entertaining you know what I
mean you get a you get a Tommy we so
felt like uh the room it's so bad that
it's great because it's so entertaining
like you go in and you are thoroughly
entertaining engrossed in what you're
watching that makes it a good movie at
least on the scale that I ascribe to
um and these ones kind of adhere to the
lower end I mean there is some joy in
them because again they're they are like
we reviewed some stuff on on VFX artist
react and the comping is just
mind-blowing that it like made it
through and yeah it's it's just his
writing in particular is like well I
mean you're talking about some of the
comping being hey I took a 2d element
and I drafted in After Effects and on
two layers and I hit it barely yeah in
fact I think Sam even made a joke on
like uh I think it was last weekend's
VFX artist react when we lost it the
freaking Steven Seagal scenes literally
like yeah there's there's no no work
done yeah you just drag it so it just
goes to show you level yeah the energy
that's going in but I mean most people
don't care because most people just know
the name and like honestly dude if you
have a name name actor he has a name
actor technically uh that's all you need
to sell a movie yeah yeah literally like
you can tell that it's it's probably
money laundering let's be honest there's
got to be something else going on there
yeah because the budgets are not like
that small but I mean we need we need
him as a character from his late 80s
movies to come in and investigate his
current movies and figure out what's
happening with the money laundering and
then defeat the bad guy that is him yes
well soon we can make that so you have a
full ECG articulate Steven Seagal now so
we have the highest Fidelity CG Steven
Seagal in the world on our server right
now Russia overlapses the rights to
Steven Seagal maybe we can uh take it
from the public domain yeah I'm very
open to ideas as to what to do with this
thing I really don't know what to do now
that we've done this should I burn it
yeah you know
you know facility that stores diseases
like what do I do with it don't do that
dude there might be a lab leak out again
yeah dude I think you need to lock it
down
they can be neighbors in prison honestly
man we have a vault where we keep all
the yeah all the too hot for the
internet that's where you put your
bowling pin yes legit we'll give them
yeah we'll put them next to each other
right there they probably belong with
each other to be honest you should go
like see two little like one muzzled as
prison muzzles
save them oh man okay so you had to
create a full fully articulate Steven
Seagal with cloth simulations yes it was
an ordeal it was one of those things
where you know Matt and I we were
talking about approaching this you know
problem of kind of extracting Steven
Seagal and putting him into the John
Wick movies and it just came down to the
the main problem being how do we really
showcase The Comedy of him always
sitting and still doing action things
with just kind of like a small sample
size of things that we could pull from
and you can Roto and replace and you
know you can get a lot of Comedy out of
that but for us on our you know Source
material there wasn't really enough to
go off and so we decided let's just
commit to making the highest quality
Stephen skull we can in the time that we
have and that will allow us to do
everything that we need to to further
like showcase The Comedy of this yeah at
the end of the day the only thing that
matters is funny we can make it better
yeah yeah and uh and that's what we did
so I went on sketchfab and I found a
thankfully somebody made a Steven Seagal
model
which is crazy
I'm a hero it was a younger it was a
younger Steven Seagal though and we
needed a very specific age of Steven
Seagal the now single right yeah and so
what I did is I just chopped his head
off and I found like a bigger body and I
frankensteined his head on and from
there I went through and I dressed him
in in a software called Marvelous
Designer
um I did all the animation inside of
Houdini with the kinefx tools and uh
yeah I did like motion capture in my own
room rolling a wheelchair firing a gun
and you know trying to capture the
essence of the Steven Seagal run and all
that fun stuff and I ran the those
through the cloth simulation side I ran
it through a hair simulation side where
we actually simulated his ponytail
flopping around and then finally did
some hair instancing on top of that
actually like hair hair follicles
essentially like a million or so on his
head just to like further bring it home
and then of course you know through the
nuke compositing pipeline that we
normally do here uh so yeah it ended up
being like quite an evolved process but
honestly looking at like the final
result it's one of the most important
shots in the entire trailer is seeing
him in the wide in that seat pulling the
trigger on that gun yeah and I'm pretty
proud of how it turned out so it landed
with the guys upstairs yeah and uh
hopefully you guys enjoyed it as well
you know but I feel like it was time
well spent but it's now a higher
Fidelity Steven Seagal than actual
Stephen yeah I mean yeah yeah yeah kind
of didn't Bruce Willis sell his likeness
he sold his likeness so he could be in
movies he just does the same kind of
thing as Segal I mean it's just like he
literally knows he can put he can sell
his name to a movie poster yeah
no no no no he's just making movies for
foreign markets yeah like essentially
he's basically making as much as he can
right now I mean yeah I mean yeah
because he has dementia yeah he has
dementia yeah it's like pretty pretty
serious yeah yeah but it's one of those
things where yeah there's okay yeah yeah
there's nothing wrong with with doing
that I think the the issue comes more of
like who Stephen is as a person you know
like yeah what we find online and the
things that we that we see in kind of
researching him there's a decent amount
of research done in that area was just
like who is Steven Seagal you know what
kind of trash movies does he make and
like how do we get the essence of that
man yeah into a John Wick movie you know
and it's it's the stories you hear as
well right like gee was on stuntman
reacting you know Steven Seagal is known
for actually hitting people in the nuts
and just beating his people beating his
freaking people up and he's not liked by
stuntmen and everywhere he goes like
based on what we were reading online his
entire path is just full of people who
don't like him after meeting him and
that says a lot about a person right
like especially when you're all about
Chi and Zen yeah
protecting the environment like he's so
uh you know he he acts a certain way
over here and then the stories you hear
about him all through his career are
this other thing and then that's the
two-sided nature and and that's where
all like the Negative Edge version dude
Bridge Burner ultimate Bridge Burner so
I didn't know much about him coming into
this thing you know I didn't feel any
particular way about Steven Seagal I
just thought his run was fun his movies
weren't very good but you know coming
out the back end I just not had a fan at
all so all right let's let's talk about
some articulable facts that yeah yeah
that's still a bad guy
yeah not a bad actor yeah it's easy to
be a bad actor well his best friend is
harder to be a bad guy
he's best friends with Putin so that's
one okay how do you know he's best
friends he's not I don't know
he's he's friendly with him yeah yeah I
mean Putin loves him because he loves a
good strong man in a leather coat right
I mean he doesn't know you know he
doesn't know I mean shoot that's
actually what's actually kind of funny
about that is like uh because he lives
in Russia now
um and uh does he yeah and I think
that's like Putin created he he made him
a citizen I think specifically to like
uh uh what was it like strength and ties
between Washington and Moscow and so
like interesting and but it wasn't
because he wanted to be his friend but
like Steven Seagal always boasts that
like they're good friends like their
Pals but like it's clear that he just
kind of wanted like a way to you know
sort of get like the American culture
integrated
ambassador of America
yeah if you pull up his Wikipedia
there's also like a a laundry list of
sexual assault allegations yeah and I
know that there's the the debate that I
was trying to believe yeah that's what I
can believe the thing you always come
into is like obviously it's a very
slippery slope and it's innocent until
proven guilty right that's the idea here
in this country and you know when you
see it so many times come up again and
again and again it's like that that
doesn't happen to people like all these
different people like some of the lines
that
he uses apparently he's right he writes
for himself the lines that he's writing
for himself and some of these movies
like we had to cut them because they
were too lewd and cringy yeah even
include as a joke about him yeah and
they're being said to very young women
incredibly low budget films I mean these
are people who are probably trying to
make it in the industry yeah he's a name
and you you kind of just suck it up and
go you know what let's just deal with it
I know it's gross it's uncomfortable
just let him say it to you it's fine and
then you know you end up with these
movies oh yeah and also he has sex with
all of these women too in his movies
that he writes on in the in the movie no
he's wearing clothes yeah yeah yeah no
he's always in clubs that to me with the
hero complex with like I write my movies
and then you put the girl in the movie
that you like want to get with but like
you're doing it in a movie it's it's
just so
bad it is and it's one of those things
where I mean I'm going to say allegedly
with all this because obviously you know
I'm not sure how these court cases
turned out or whatever but there were a
few things that I read where it happened
in the audition room too where you know
on one audition on camera what it was
but he's basically saying how important
it is to have off-screen chemistry as
he's like unzipping his fly that was the
allegation and he's not the only they're
not you know there's not one instance of
him doing this and that's not slander if
it's true okay yeah I just yeah I don't
know yeah I don't know man it's just
it's all so ugly and uncomfortable this
is what this is specifically what it was
um it was a audition uh and I think she
got through like a couple of rounds of
these audition processes right
um and you know so she was about to be
cast but he was like this was like final
stages and she was
um just there Steven Seagal a couple
other producers uh in the room casting
and uh I think Steven just goes okay
well uh can you could you like take your
clothes off for the you know just so we
can have an idea of you know what you
look like for the sex scene
um and she was like well I I talked to
my agent and we've confirmed that there
was like no nudity in this film right
this is a this is no I'm not doing
nudity and he's like no but there's off
camera nudity
what like what does that mean what is
that camera nudity what's off camera
they know what that is but we know what
that is yeah that's yeah that's that's
something it's like what the hell does
that mean that's not part of the
contract
doesn't make any sense yeah it's crazy
man and just I mean you know another
another element of this man's ego and
just how kind of wrapped up in himself
is he he is is you know the idea that he
never accepts that his character dies
like they're the ones I showed Sam and
Nico on the couch uh what movie is that
from
um end of a gun I think no I can't
remember which one it is it's the one
where he rolls through the glass and
Falls oh [__] I don't know whatever the
heck of Honor there we go I hate that I
know the title yeah right now
we're gonna have a quiz for you on all
57 yes I've watched 10 of them that's
way too much Lord in in code of honor
the writer director was basically saying
in an interview he's like well I wrote
it so that you know the character that
Stephen Scott was playing is is dead
like it's implied that he died you know
he's a vigilante who got hunted down or
whatever I haven't seen the movie don't
care to but that was the idea is that
his character died and Stevens look all
just denied it he's like no I didn't no
he didn't no he's just not no he didn't
die got away and he to this day refuses
to accept that his character died and
it's like mate it doesn't matter it's
imaginary it's fictional it doesn't it
doesn't you're not it's okay like it's
not real though that's what I want to
say that just gives you an insight into
he yeah he's just he is the character
and the character is Steven Seagal yeah
there's no separation so he sees himself
as it's like that's like my greatest
fear of making videos is you become the
caricature of yourself oh gosh man yeah
you wake up in a dark place and you're
like how did I get here especially when
the caricature is so darn dark as well
like yeah and so so you know if you
dwell too much on the specifics of this
guy it gets really dark and really sad
really fast and so it's like that's also
what we were kind of battling and making
this is like we still wanted it to be a
fun video yeah yeah but it is about a
guy who you know on paper and from what
we've read is just like
there aren't that many you know total
scumbags in the world who put so much
effort into humiliating themselves for
the whole world yeah yeah at least we
have that to think and we can all sit
around and laugh at it and you know yeah
we do yeah trying to extract some Joy
looking at it Nick yeah
so yeah yeah Play-Doh Play-Doh cut half
it's the fumes it's the Play-Doh
again I'm over here for sure so Matt uh
what was the
hardest part about putting this whole
thing together because we often task you
with these sort of impossible ideas
which is like hey we got this we need
Matt get in here we need you we got this
crazy idea or you got a crazy idea or
whatever and we we we're like we're
gonna Mash Up
Steven Seagal yeah and John Wick so how
do you even approach that as an artist
oh
okay so
um first of all you just gotta watch the
the movies you have to watch live in the
material for a while yeah like it was
the same with something like a
Spider-Man rated R or a saw like those
things needed just a lot of just like
days of just marinating in the content
and and that way you can like refer to
stuff lit later like if there's a story
you want to tell you can go like okay
well I remember seeing that scene in
this movie like you really just have to
be super familiar with the material that
you're working with um that helps a lot
um so yes I had to watch 10 10 cigar
movies
um so many hours a a YouTuber named
space ice uh who has like space ice
because honestly I would not have the
mental capacity to do this because I'm
certainly not watching 57 of singles
movies notes comedy cliff notes for
Seagal videos yeah
he should be in the crew video too I
mentioned it oh okay so yeah that he
should get a little shout out in the
crew video
um but it was super important because uh
it meant that I didn't have to download
57 of his [__] movies I only had to
download 10. because I knew the ones
that would work for a John Wick style uh
film right something that has the same
similar kind of wardrobe sort of like
Gunplay similar Vibes uh just scenes and
funny moments that I knew I could
probably use in a John Wick uh style
trailer to find those elements like
what's that was it hard to find those
elements like did he does he have a lot
of stuff that's actually good enough to
like be cut in how often would you say
in a given film does he look like John
Wick
zero percent okay zero percent of ten or
is it like 0.5 I think it's more about
because the thing is our goal here was
to stress tests John Wick as a franchise
so we still want the seagull Essence we
don't want him to feel cool we're we
want him to be like as if you cast the
goal in this role um and Seagal's gonna
do some gold stuff right
um but like the idea is like well what
kind of movies have that John Wick
lighting you know like what movies can I
match that lighting to scenes in John
Wick uh be able to put him in those
scenes and make it feel realistic uh
there's a couple of shots in the trailer
that I'm pretty proud of that's not CG
it's just like Roto Brute Force like
copping work uh and it works pretty well
because the lighting matches
um and you know he has some similar eye
line and gesturing
um but yeah that stuff is literally just
like just watching a bunch of clips and
then stringing that out on a timeline
cutting the moments where you're like
well I've watched these three John Wick
movies this many times I know the story
I'm trying to tell in this trailer and
now I know how to inject that moment
into it
so object you did it's definitely a
little bit of a mind F though it takes a
minute but uh you can get there believe
in yourself well because you ended up
yeah don't do this though
but I think the true the true
artisanship in addition to what you said
is also in in the fact that you
recontextualized it oh yeah to be
if John Wick was a Steven Seagal movie
yeah right so yeah you're right that's
the other thing is that it's not it's
not just about making a John Wick movie
it's about like casting Steven Seagal on
the role and telling the story as if
Steven Seagal is the star so yeah you
know the the the fact that his the one
thing that he'd care about most is not
his dog or his wife he wouldn't give a
[__] about his wife if he had one it
doesn't matter at all women matter very
little to him he's got four in Thailand
yeah yeah I've got another
um but what he cares about the most is
his ability to sit down as often as
possible yeah this is something that we
were talking about yeah something we
were talking about it's like you know
it's like what does he love more does he
love himself does he look like is it a
bust of himself that breaks right is it
is it just taking his chair away from
him so he can't be comfortable yeah like
what is it that would make this man as
mad as Keanu was losing his dog and John
Wick I think we arrived at the chair
because it was also a great payoff to
the Run yeah it was a great way to be
like nah I'm not I'm not just standing
I'm running yeah yeah that's that's
great so yeah I mean like you said Jake
it's like you gotta have a story in mind
and it can't just be the story of John
Wick you got to tell your own story you
know you're a filmmaker you're a
Storyteller you got to tell your own uh
you got to make your own narratives you
know spin this this web
of weirdness yeah so yeah um yeah I
think that's the thing that that really
makes it special though is is we didn't
just put Steven Seagal and John Wick we
imagined well you imagined John Wick as
a Steven Seagal
video Yeah Steven Seagal movie
yeah you gotta like live in the universe
a little bit Yeah God I don't want to go
back though no no like I said don't ever
do it was a pit stop don't take mine
guys please watch these videos so Matt's
sacrifice was not made in vain please
those brain cells are permanently gone
that way if it goes really viral then
we'll definitely want to make a bunch
more yes
[Laughter]
it does feel very similar to when we did
the mobile game ad yeah like it does the
amount of dude of dum-dum in my brain
right now it feels like it's on similar
oh yeah us writing us writing the the
mobile game at just trying to come up
with the concept itself just meant we
had to turn our brains all the way up
like like we want to like pick up a book
or something just like kind of like you
know get back to where you were yeah we
have a running gag right now with
Griffin too where you know there used to
be a show called mancers which was like
the most obnoxiously male just base
humor thing and you know we'll just come
up with random things like how many
farts would it take to power the sun
like all those things that you'd see on
Spike TV and it feels like that is
existing right now because of the amount
of just dumb in the air yeah so much
dumb in there from these projects and
it's kind of a beautiful thing yeah dude
but maybe I've just forgotten what life
is like on the other side yeah I don't
know man I don't know the serious world
of VFX supervisor yeah man set being the
go-to guy yeah just the angry people on
Saturday yeah who doesn't want more of
that in their life yeah I want to get
angry yeah
man yeah I don't know man I'm really
proud of it like it's fun it's a fun one
it's a great workout and getting the
reactions like that's always my favorite
part personally to see for sure seeing
people react to for the first time and
when jokes land that you know we were
really not sure if they were going to
it's like it's very it's very satisfying
oh yeah that's the other thing is like
getting jokes to land requires like
showing it to a lot of people and
especially showing it to like funny
people like I showed people outside of
corridor as well that I respect as
Comedians and especially like filmmaking
Comedians and like just to like tweak
Cuts sometimes it's like shaving frames
off of stuff to make stuff funnier makes
a difference uh yeah getting jokes to
land is super hard and it's like you you
can only like laugh at something
yourself as a filmmaker so much like
there's a point where you have to like
take a step back and ask other people
instead of just like going I know this
is funny yeah you get exactly the way it
is well a good example of that is like
you know we had a that's a Seagal move
yeah
it's funny and I don't die at the end
yeah no it's it's not and you do
um no it's
um it's yeah it's it's one of those
things where you know we had a cut
finished and and we were very happy with
it and we saw Stephen you know the CG
version of Steven Seagal we call him
Stephen Siege Gall we we see him in
three three separate Cuts but they were
so quick that we could register what was
going on because we knew it was coming
yeah but when Nico saw it for the first
time his reaction was ah I wanna you
should Linger on that like I feel like
Linger on that shot in particular of him
sitting down shooting and it was
literally a result of you know me and
Matt talking about it and then I had to
start the shot from scratch from the
beginning all over again yeah and uh and
uh honestly like looking at the result
between the two it was the right move
and we never would have thought of that
with without having fresh eyes from an
outside perspective it's always good for
that man the Gorski wins for sure yeah
yeah anything that's not strong enough
to withstand the wins
yeah get blown away yeah
how much fun was it though for you
Jordan to do all the motion capture in
the channel the best man the best the
videos I took from home when I was when
I was doing the mocap is it they're
chaotic can we see a like a side by side
of that at some point for social media
yeah that would actually personally like
it I'll put one together because yeah
that it was it was a hoot man and just
trying to embody the spirit you know I
think I I ate like three pounds of
cheese yeah and then I looked myself in
the I looked at myself in the mirror and
said you're the greatest you're the
greatest of all time I put on a durag
and I got to work baby
man
in the form of a mocap suit oh man oh
gross too rag for your body yeah yeah I
put on the mo cap suit and then I put a
leather jacket on over it
gosh man how is he a real person and
that's what blows my mind dude he has so
many like weird business ventures too
like weird energy drinks have you heard
of his energy drink Jake no what's it
called oh okay you haven't heard of his
energy drink what's it called lightning
bolt I think oh yeah okay it is it's not
just lightning bolt because you know how
like a lot of celebrities like they'll
they'll create
um maybe Spirits like alcohols and stuff
but you won't really they won't have
their names on it necessarily it'll be a
little bit more subtle you just know
it's made by the celebrity well uh this
energy drink is called Steven Seagal's
lightning bolt and Steven Seagal is
right on the front cover his picture of
his face is on the cover on the front a
little bit of my ejaculate and
everything yeah
the funny part is like they went out wow
by the way that just hit me I just got
okay so you got the slash damage
Splash Zone
those energy drink companies out of
business yeah yeah yeah
you can still find them you can still
find them they're actually expensive on
eBay but I gotta tell you if you do look
them up you'll find that there are two
different flavors okay and the names of
them are hilarious uh one is called
Cherry charge which makes sense makes
sense right that's a that's the name of
the logo yes the logo is great any
listeners please look it up well when
you're not driving uh so there's Cherry
charge and then the other one which
looks like a blueberry or something is
called the Asian experience
and the commercial for it is of course
him in a freaking Sun chair and a sexy
girl in the pool who is very interested
in him
listener please if you dare look up the
commercial on YouTube Just
I'm seeing still frames of it guys yeah
okay if you're listening you have to
watch it there's Steven Seagal sitting
in a lounging chair next to a pool with
a Hawaiian shirt on and sunglasses with
his hair pulled back with holding up the
energy drink which has this ridiculous
Asian Japanese some some lettering on it
it's the Asian experience I guess it's
mixed them all together yeah and then
with a lightning bolt behind it yeah
well there's a girl in like a small
bikini yellow bikini who looks like
she's probably 18 maybe yeah like like
that's his commercial he could be her
Grandpa yeah yeah
baby oh my God guys it's awful dude
don't work it's so uncomfortable it's
like everyone's like creepy Grandpa yeah
you know like has too much money to
spend on stuff
I have created this all-natural energy
drink packed with vitamins and exotic
Botanicals wow of course it could always
be a normal sentence
yeah he also has a an aftershave he does
like the name of the aftershave Shake oh
yeah
you ready for this uh is it real I
remember his aftershave and I'm gonna
buy it for you Jake for uh secret santa
it's a scent of action
of action
is that sweat is that just sweat blood
actually blood a little bit of blood in
there too Blood Sweat and Black
Goose
sweating it's just an excuse for Bo he's
like that's Descent of action baby yeah
yeah I'm sorry do I oh yeah
don't mind the action so I've been
sitting down kicking people all day yeah
it's difficulty
wow man what a what a what a joke what a
human being I said
what a gem before and then I caught
myself I'm like yeah what is the right
turn it's not Jim because he is like
he's one of those people it's crazy that
he exists and it's like there's so much
joy in like just looking at him just
going what yeah and my default is what a
gem but yeah I think what a blood
diamond is probably much it's kind of
accurate it's like a car accident where
you don't want to watch it but you also
can't look away yeah you know true it's
uh so you know what he's carved out that
little piece of of our culture for
himself right yeah maybe you just
appreciate that you know yeah yeah or or
not or please don't yeah I don't know
man it becomes hard the more I learn the
harder and harder it becomes to separate
the art from the artists you know what I
mean if any of those
[__] yeah it's a stretch regardless
here's something from somebody
commenting on his uh scent of action oh
yeah uh all right uh well uh
so here's what he says I Harbor a deep
love for the Sensei no matter how pudgy
overdubbed and stunt doubled he may have
to come I have a feeling that this could
be a life-changing Splash oh yeah wow
that's a rave review what does the scent
described as
yeah is there like Botanicals in it
is it an Asian experience yeah
let's make a product just called west of
the Atlantic yeah I like that yeah west
of the Atlantic experience yeah and it's
just grape it's like this is great
that's great I guess
that flavor here
job
boring man
yeah I want to know what scent of action
smells like I'm genuinely curious yeah
this is from February 11th that's 2010
okay it's been said that Steven Seagal
makes aftershave that's right the Steven
Seagal one called scent of action
another called oh he's got another one
another called scent of energy
if such a thing exists I must have it
Seagal's website is of no help surprise
surprise surprise
shaky is to give unreliability a bad
name wow anybody know any details this
could give mandum a run for the money
what is mandum I have no idea I feel
like we're opening a door here to a
whole nother World he's about to get
more traffic than he's gotten in years
Steven seagal.com immediately I go to
stevensegal.com and Viagra is the first
thing that pops up no immediately Viagra
is Super Active because I guess that's
Steven Seagal that's not what happened
that's not real
this is this is a real website it's this
is it all just medical enhancements it's
not made by Steven Steven see all is not
my personal selling here's one of the
letters Russia and American humanitarian
ties dear friends today I am deeply
humble and honored to have been
appointed as a special representative of
the Russian foreign Ministry there you
go
yeah I'm sorry I'm so suddenly he leaned
all the way
it's a place I'm I'm sorry are you
getting here at the same time we'll
crash the website are you getting
through to stevensegal.com because I'm
getting redirected to an online pharmacy
I think it's just a nonsense
yeah mine's definitely just Viagra it's
saying it's saying online your
connection is not secure so okay so I've
certainly been hacked I I don't think
it's HT https bro okay
I'm gonna get off this yeah this is
certainly not the website okay he's got
guys oh my God please if this is like an
HTML site from 2000 it's got tabs at the
tracks shoot do we
film
we can't get Justice series other work
do you want to see what his other work
is I'd love it too yeah what other works
is he up to oh well he's got the energy
drinks on there okay
due to his satire over the years Stephen
has been asked to both promote and star
in many non-film Productions from
product commercials to lighthearted
Cameo roles in this other work section
oh my God this is such a 2000s website
in this other work section we aim to
highlight and bring together some of the
very best of his work For Your
Entertainment please follow the links
below for a more detailed information
wow he has a whole like introductory
paragraph like hey you guys are gonna
need a little bit of an orientation
before you look at my other yeah yeah I
like how that's that's that's very
pretty
wow oh his philanthropy would you guys
like to read about his philanthropy oh
I'd love to know what he's doing
philanthropy all right here we go Jen
sit back kick back relax and let's just
hear about some of the wonderful
philanthropic actions that Mr Sir Steven
Seagal has taken some of Steven's
greatest accomplishments greatest
accomplishments in life are with the
Charities he supports and has started
Stephen is a man who extends his success
to various philanthropic causes
including needy children around the
world the environment animal rights and
AIDS projects okay his deep love and
care for his family and the human race
is exemplified in his commitment to do
his part to make this world better okay
please please so would you please list
them there are just a few awards that
Stephen has been honored with over the
years 1991 first annual environmental
media Awards
wow the first annual first annual I love
how quickly it jumps to his accolades
I'm not about others but him
Peta humanitarian award 1999.
I mean that kind of shows you the
mindsets like he's such an
environmentalist so and to prove it
check out all my yeah
he's sick yeah Sashi 2001 humanitarian
award that's a big one okay that's a big
one honored as the first
what okay guys what percent of action
what are you reading honored as the
first private citizen to destroy a
nuclear device no no
no what is he doing
they're probably demilitarizing it let's
see did this freaking Judo chopping it
what could that technically be what does
technically a nuclear device
like uh honored as honored as the first
wait is
the first human to who honored him the
the device the Council of devices
Council of devices did he like beat an
atomic clock or something yeah right I
don't know yeah
first private citizen destroy a nuclear
weapon
[Music]
my interest
s
are you making a little curvy Crusader
yeah it looks like it's almost like oh
oh it does yeah it is is it I'm making
it longer and longer to show the camera
that yeah
that's an elf hat right okay what do you
think it is oh it's oh that's what I
thought immediately yeah I saw it too
yeah elf hat elf house
very tiny hat for tiny men oh my gosh
Jake have you found any more I can't
find any more info on this Jen we should
just trust it was on these website right
no it's on his website oh you can't do
that you can't just put it on your
website if it's not you can't just make
stuff up you can't just make stuff up
okay no uh it's illegal here we go
also claims to be the first private
citizen to destroy a nuclear device this
assertion oh my God okay here we go
this assertion is based on a 100 000
donation he made to the global nuclear
disarmament Fund in 2005. he celebrated
that donation by hosting an event where
Zen monks brought a FL sorry I just got
bombarded by ads whereas Zen monks
brought a flame supposedly lit from the
fires of Hiroshima
to what to the original nuclear bomb
test site in New Mexico for a full
circle ceremony
the monks carried the flame to the site
by walking it
for more than 1500 miles from San
Francisco to New Mexico what the heck
that sounds really safe for the monks by
the way yeah take people like and just
have them carry a nuke across the with a
radioactive flame a flame from from the
blast
that's
so lame so so let me get this so wait so
let me so he could say that he yes he's
the guy who killed the nuke
yeah
sorry Matt I know your mind has already
been blown by this but I just I'm trying
to I'm trying to make sure I understand
so he donated a hundred thousand dollars
to a fund
and then that fund found some monks
claimed to have a flame that originated
from the original Hiroshima blast they
brought that all the way to New Mexico
apparently walking 1500 miles of which
there's no mention of any kind so that
he could put it out to so that he could
put it out
no I I think the fund was that hundred
thousand dollars I think he just you
know probably this is just speculate
obviously I'm just guessing but he
probably just paid I don't understand
why didn't they just fly it to New
Mexico
dude if monks do it it's super spiritual
and hella meaningful but they flew from
Hiroshima question it two don't ask San
Francisco how did they fly in the plane
with the nuclear plane in the plane yeah
all right were they holding out the
window one little Ember did they nurse
an ember yeah did they nurse an Amber
back to life and create a flame that he
then blew out like a candle and then
claimed I need to know yeah that's what
it sounds like it sounds like they
literally took a flame that they say
originated from the original Hiroshima
blast they took a part of that flame
they brought it all the way to New
Mexico just so that Steven Seagal could
put it out to claim that he disarmed a
nuclear bomb you have perfectly
encapsulated Steven Seagal yeah
I've ever heard that is the most sick
all truly so that he can put on the
website that he was the first private
citizen to disarm a nuclear bomb which
didn't actually disarm a nuclear bomb
and we might be the first people to read
it but he doesn't care because to him he
did it yeah I guarantee you he would
argue with you that he did oh I
guarantee you sure and that she
certainly would that's what we're
dealing with here folks yeah that's who
he is how do you beat that man that is a
great a surprising fact that does
summarize him in a lot of ways my
brother when we when we were growing up
my brother Oh I thought you were gonna
say like my brother my brother no my
brother when we were growing up he had
this horrifically annoying tendency to
to be never give up in an argument yeah
my brother basically but he would just
say no it's not no it's not no it's not
and he would brag to me saying I've
never lost an argument because as long
as I don't stop saying no it's not no
matter what I'm presented they will give
up and I will win now he grew up
but this is the same thing uh-huh yeah
this is the same this is that that no
but not grown up this is Steven Seagal
yeah if he stopped growing at 12 and
then it became a full-fledged adult man
no it blows my mind like he just know
it's not you into just going okay Steven
sure you put out the first thing put out
the nuke man well done it why not that
is some serious uh what do you call it
like um
Psychopathic but sociopathic yeah yeah
his main character it's a major main
character energy just hijacking
spirituality for vainglorious efforts
yeah oh yeah oh I mean he takes credit
for teaching you know professional
fighters the move that won them the
fight you know he does it with
everything whatever he touches is like
sounds like he needs some professional
help yeah yeah it's just a better help
was that an MMA thing right yeah because
didn't he he just like told them to do a
move like just hey like kick him in the
head and then they did it in the fight
he's like you listened yeah you're
welcome
he's like
if you're looking at his website
if you look on his website he probably
put that down as a win for him and his
professional and the maker he won it I'm
not 1-0 in the UFC champion
Steven Seagal is the only one to have
won a UFC fight outside of the Ring I
was actually competing I at them
internally because you know how they had
all had all that Norris memes or it's
like Chuck Norris is so blah blah blah
that he blah blah the whole thing I bet
hey I bet that really I bet he was
miffed about that I bet he was quite
upset that is like not him but I
disowned a nuclear bomb that the monks
brought
the most part
where where is the logic where in the
Stream of logic are you like I put out
the flame so I disarmed a nuclear bomb
that's crazy
oh man I believe it can't do it okay
because I can't because to not believe
it takes more energy
I do need it
whatever look guys I'm gonna say this
right now I have had enough Stevens to
go for the rest of my life I think we're
kind of done talking about this honestly
I'm over it the video's done we're
moving I'm gonna just eat the rest of
this Play-Doh and move on with my life
okay in conclusion let's talk about some
happy thoughts yeah
what are we doing what are we doing
after this guys what are we doing next
are we doing something better
and you stayed all the way to the end of
the podcast guess what we're making
another episode of punch for punch this
time about extraction two yeah it's sick
it is yeah we've seen some stuff that
will blow you away that's all I'll say
legit it is very cool and then Jake and
I I don't it wouldn't be out yet no of
course it wouldn't our dude perfect for
CG render challenge two the sequel oh
that's fun that's coming up so stay
tuned for this week
get your underground betting ring built
get it prepped get that cash in hand and
get that Dash in hand and start making
bets no dude we have a lot of fun stuff
coming up yeah that doesn't relate to
Steven Seagal and honestly like just to
kind of surmise look end of the day yeah
whoever he is that's great whatever
moving on from him creating it was a ton
of fun yeah like making it and the
creative challenge of trying to put him
in it and we had a lot of Hoots and
hollers along the way it's a really fun
it was a really fun time another day at
the office yes sir just another day
freaking looked over your shoulder one
day and you're like freaking cutting the
seams of a Seagal like what are they
called the thing he wears no yeah the
traditional
yeah Griffin walked by it as I was
pulling down his jean pants to reveal
his buttocks for one of the shots man I
wish I'd seen and uh yeah we had to talk
about that in private work through that
one together yeah Griffin is like the
kid who's seen too much and doesn't know
what to say
and I'm not kidding his timing is
impeccable he walks by at the worst
moment every time he's the my peer
version of my mom when I was a kid going
don't come in at the worst part of every
show it's like just the one shot that
shows that like the rest of it doesn't
do that that's Griffin all the time at
the office yeah it's kind of a beautiful
thing that's a poor guy that's funny oh
bless him
oh that's amazing Griffin I swear we're
not making a whole video about Steven
Seagal's butt
please believe us man we tried really
hard
that's beautiful is that at the end
that's it yeah that's it there it is so
Zen what is that ending don't hate it
Matt thanks for tuning in everybody
we're gonna cut out now Matt's eating
Play-Doh
um yeah thanks for joining us and uh as
always thanks for being a true ton yeah
let's go put out some nukes with some
Palms put out some nukes huh
[Laughter]
I hired these monks for like a whole day
I don't know what else to do with them
what else could they carry around two
hours here here ordain me as like a
reincarnated uh
see you later